>> Hi, YouTube.
My name is Jennifer Schenker.
I'm the technology journalist for Business
Week in Europe.
Uh, I've never been on YouTube before.
This is a first.
Uh, I'm here in Davos covering technology
people.
The companies but also all, uh, of the creative
non companies that
form the technology pioneers this year.
I'm convinced that technology can help mac
the world a better place,
umm, particularly by linking with, umm, social
projects.
So if you have a -- if you're a social entrepreneur
and you've got a
project you think, uh, could really benefit
the use of technology to
scale up, write me and, uh, I'll try to find
the right person here for
you to connect with and try to do my part
to help make the world a
better place in 2008.
Thanks.